bonjour marie de virginie bonjour vous
êtes l'une des porte parole de l'union
populaire républicaine upr qui présente
un candidat à la présidentielle
française il s'agit de françois
asselineau vous êtes une jeune
martiniquaise d'une trentaine d'années
madame de virginie qu'est ce qui à ce
qu'est ce qui vous a séduit dans le
discours de cet homme est dans ce parti
qui viennent de célébrer ses dix ans
d'existence
alors ce qui m'a plu chez françois
asselineau c'est son discours de vérité
c'est à dire que avant de le connaître
sur internet
je ne comprenais pas je n'arrivais pas à
décrypter l'actualité politique au
niveau national et je ne comprenais pas
pourquoi est ce que malgré l'alternance
des gouvernements de droite et de gauche
la france va de plus en plus mal et on
va vers une paupérisation de la société
et puis grâce aux conférences qui sont
très longues d'ailleurs entre 3 et 4
heures surtout plus parfois plus j'ai
réussi à comprendre finalement que ce
qui se passe en france c'est que la
politique les grandes orientations
politiques ne sont pas décidés au niveau
national mais au niveau européen
et ça ça change tout les son discours à
vous à réconcilier avec ce monde
politique
non ça m'a pas avec le monde politique
pas tel qu'il est en ce moment mais ça
m'a réconcilié avec l'idée que quand on
a on a des choses à défendre qu'il faut
se lever qu'il faut résister qu il faut
militer parce que la politique
contrairement à ce que à ce que j'ai
j'ai été amené à penser au fil du temps
ça sert à quelque chose
vous avez parlé de discours de vérité de
la part de françois sinon ça veut dire
que les autres sont des discours de
mensonges ça veut dire que oui il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont dites et qui
sont et qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
vraies je vais vous donner un exemple
chaque fois qu'un homme politique vous
dis bon tout le monde est d'accord on
puisse y ait un consensus pour dire il
ya un problème avec l'europe et on veut
d'une nouvelle europe il faut changer
l'europe quand on est à gauche on veut à
une europe plus sociale quand on est à
droite on veut une europe plus libérale
la vérité c'est que on ne peut pas
changer l'europe et sa
il faut comprendre les mécanismes pour
comprendre à quel point c'est un
mensonge et à quel point on se fait en
fumée comme des renards mais chaque fois
que quelqu'un vous dit il faut changer
l'europe
iman et le des points forts du discours
de françois c'est moche c'est justement
cette sortie de l'europe l'europe quand
même qui on va le rappeler c'est 60 ans
de paix sur le territoire intérieur
l'europe s'est par exemple les
programmes erasmus qui favorise les
échanges des voyages la jeunesse vous
avez peut-être pu profiter de ce fameux
programme européen et vous voulez sortir
de tout ça aussi alors je vais préciser
le propos la france
littéralement ne peut pas sortir de
l'europe va pas se mettre dans l'océan
atlantique sorte de l'union européenne
ça c'est différent le programme
d'asselineau est très clair sortir de
l'union européenne sortir de l'euro et
sortir de l'otan je rebondis sur ce que
vous avez dit l'europe c'est la paix non
c'est faux en fait la raison pour
laquelle il n'ya plus de guerre en
europe celle équilibre des forces
c'est la dissuasion nucléaire c'est tout
ça n'a rien à voir avec la construction
européenne ensuite vous parler des
programmes erasmus
désolé ça ça n'a rien à voir avec la
construction européenne ce sont des
traités qui n'ont rien à voir avec lieu
je vous promets de façon très négative
beaucoup de gens parlent de lui et du
pr1 presque comme une sorte de secte
complotistes est pour vous la bête dont
il faut couper la tête c'est forcément
l'union européenne oui oui enfin la bête
antichoc et des expressions a fait image
et non ce que je veux dire c'est que la
france et la martinique ou intérêt à
sortir de l'union européenne je m'en
sois sino a parlé récemment de d'hugo p
en fait ce sont des ddt choses et textes
qu'ils sont
décrite par la commission européenne et
qui n'ont de recommandations que de que
le nom en fait les commissaires dont on
ne connaît pas le nom dont on ne sait
pas qui n'ont jamais été soumis au vote
des populations décident des politiques
roth
si vous voulez décident des politiques
économiques sociales monétaires de pays
qui n'ont rien à voir
est ce que vous voyez la différence
entre l'économie de la pologne de
l'allemagne de l'italie et de la france
ces gens n'ont aucun intérêt à forcer de
lensois avec les eurodéputés cadeaux ils
font entendre leur voix
avec vous parce que vous croyez vraiment
que le parlement a du pouvoir
moi et mes je vous invite sincèrement et
parce que là on est dans une dictature
douce qui s'impose aux gens par le sa
complexité et par l'ennui c'est à dire
que quand vous essayez d'en savoir
davantage vous allez sur internet
les textes sont darche tint pas d'un
chiant mais les textes sont très
compliquées on n'arrive pas à comprendre
et ccd technique d'enfumage et c'est
tellement ennuyeux qu'on n'essaye pas
d'en savoir davantage alors face à
françois ses emails upr propose au
programme de libération nationale n'est
ce pas ce que dit marine le pen dans sa
vision de l'europe pour la candidate
frontiste
elle aussi elle veut en sortir well va
en sortir oui et non c'est à dire que
d'abord elle veut renégocier
c'est c'est pas possible de renégocier
ce année c'est un peu littéralement
c'est impossible d'ailleurs je vous mets
au défi de me citer une personne un seul
chef d'état ou de gouvernement qui a
réussi à négocier avec l'union
européenne et qui a obtenu gain de cause
ça n'existe pas il ya une raison marine
le pen elle elle veut renégocier puis
ensuite elle veut soumettre à un
référendum coût élevé un coup elle veut
pas nous ce qu'on dit c'est clair
françois asselineau est le candidat du
frac site
on sort un point c'est tout c'est
vraiment l'europe le danger oublier les
états unis
on sait c'est l'europe et pour la france
en tout cas et pour les intérêts de la
france et de la martinique la
construction européenne ne va pas dans
le sens de nos intérêts françois steyn
ont été notre candidat hors système non
et ici il n'y a jamais dit qu'il était
un candidat diplômé de hec de l'ena
ancien directeur de cabinet de françois
de françoise de panafieu lorsqu'il était
ministre dans le gouvernement d'alain
juppé collaborateurs de l'ancien
ministre gérard longuet lycée de quoi il
parle alors oui non mais sincèrement pc
soit qu'il ait connu je pense parce
qu'il a déjà énormément d'expérience il
connaît les arcanes du pouvoir il
connaît et si vous voulez le
fonctionnement de toutes les
institutions françaises et européennes
et c'est un candidat qui à mon sens est
très crédible dans le programme de
françois ces îlots j'ai vu un petit
passage qui demande un éclaircissement
ils demandent qu'on fixe un cadre
constitutionnel pour les médias on a
déjà parlé de son de sa volonté de
renationaliser le groupe tf1 mais le
cadre constitutionnel aux médias ça
voudrait dire que les médias doivent
devenir eux doivent être aux ordres
non voilà vous aller un peu loin en faux
contre votre interprétation non ça veut
dire simplement qu'il faut pouvoir
redonner la liberté aux journalistes
non mais sincèrement je vais vous donner
un exemple quand françois asselineau dit
ben moi je propose de re nationaliser
tf1 parce que ses lacets renationaliser
pas nationalisées on va pas à les
nationaliser bfm relationniste parce que
tf1 avait eu une charte de 2 en termes
de culture qui n'a jamais surtout le
groupe audiovisuel le plus puissant de
france c'est ça et tout le monde tout le
monde
[Musique]
choqué par cette proposition par contre
récemment je vois passer une vidéo de
monsieur de villepin qui explique à
l'époque où il s'était présenté au
président présidentielle que avec son
mécène du mit goldsmith il a acheté 4,99
% des actions de tf1 et des sondages
donc ça veut dire que les médias ne sont
pas les journalistes en tout cas ne sont
pas libres d'exercer leur métier de
leurs tautologique des journalistes ben
est ce que j'en fais c'est que déjà ce
que je constate c'est que quand françois
asselineau en parle et journalistes ne
savent pas de quoi il s'agit
marie de virginie pour la martinique
on a parlé tout à l'heure de l'union
européenne vous savez que l'union
européenne a quand même permis à la
banane antillaise de d'exister sur le
marché européen
l'union européenne est là pour financer
les grands projets structurants
vous dites quoi aux martiniquais a lieu
aujourd'hui moi ce que je leur dis c'est
que l'argent de l'europe
en fait c'est de l'argent français ya
dans l'union européenne des
contributeurs nets et des bénéficiaires
nets ce qui signifie que d'un côté les
contributeurs nets donne plus d'argent
qu'il n'en reçoivent et celle inverse
pour les bénéficiaires
ce qui signifie concrètement en chiffres
que la france verse 23 milliards d'euros
à l'union européenne
henin récupère que 14 60 serait mieux de
garder son temps et les gens qui mais
oui parce que c'est vraiment c6 sais
c'est pas possible d'imaginer que on
arrive à enfumer les gens
de telle sorte qu'ils pensent que d'un
côté on a la gentille europe qui va
donner des fonds qui va donner l'argent
qui va qui va soutenir des projets d'un
autre côté on a l'état français qui est
de plus en plus en retrait qui baissent
les dotations qui qui qui qui qui met en
difficulté les
les villes et communes sais c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe non la banane
aurait intérêt en sortant de l'euro je
vais même vous dire ce que ça va faire
les subventions le reste va se montre
comment la seconde williams a voté
françois asselineau et allez vous
renseigner sur internet allait regarder
les conférences essayer de comprendre
vous savez à l'heure d'internet ne pas
connaître les choses c'est un choix
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
marie de virginie on rappelle que vous
êtes porte parole de l'union populaire
républicaine avec un candidat françois
seynod bonne journée
merci
[Musique]